This is the world as Vincent van Gogh saw
it -- or, at least, how the makers of the
film "Loving Vincent" imagine he did.
They've created this animated feature as a
homage to the Dutch artist.
It's comprised of around 65-thousand frames
-- each painted in oil, by hand.
The film had its world premiere in very picturesque
surroundings in southeastern France.
"Loving Vincent" was shown as part of the renowned Annecy International Animation Film Festival.
“When you put these paintings together and
put the letters together, they almost create
like a storyboard.
So that was the main reason.
And also he fascinated me as an artist with
his incredible bravery and the passion that
still breathes life into what we’re doing.”
The film's storyline is based on around 800
letters that Vincent van Gogh wrote to his
brother Theo.
It covers the last year of the artist's life,
including his struggles with mental illness
and his eventual suicide.
“Then he comes here with a girl who, I reckon,
was out of his league, and the next thing
I hear he's killed himself.”
Around 100 of Van Gogh's paintings provided
the basis for the film's artwork.
“A big challenge was for us to be unified
as the team of painters, because they are
very different people with their artistic
background and different styles.
And all of a sudden, they all had to just
leave all of that behind.”
First, the scenes were filmed using actors.
These images served as templates for the painters,
who recreated them frame by frame in van Gogh's
own signature style.
"The truth is: I'm not important."
The artists worked at three different locations.
Most painted their works in Gdansk, Poland.
Some 5-thousand people from around the world
had applied to take part in the project.
Around 100 made the grade.
To make the artists' work easier,
these special studios were set up.
Each one is equipped with a monitor and a
projector.
When required, the template can be projected
onto the screen.
Kateryna Ocheredko from Ukraine specializes
in portraits.
Vincent van Gogh is one of her idols.
"I use his experience for my work and for
my life.
And now I can do something for him.
I think, because he is very important and
he changes our thoughts on colors, about styles
and work in landscape.
It’s my thank you for him."
Every painting was photographed and pieced
together to create a film sequence.
It took 12 paintings to produce just one second
of film.
Their style had to remain as close as possible
to van Gogh's,
but at times they had to get creative.
"Van Gogh painted various canvas sizes, so
sometimes we had to invent a little bit to
the right and to the left.
Sometimes for script reasons we actually had
to change the season.
So we had to change a little bit the color
scheme in some of the paintings a bit.
But we tried to show most of the paintings
as true to the original at some point in the
film as we can."
At the Animation Film Festival in Annecy,
the film seems to have found its audience.
“That everything is animated and that they're
all paintings is just....I can hardly believe it.
And the play of light and shadow, and that
everything is also painted in impressionist style..."
“You were really caught up in the paintings
of Vincent van Gogh.
This film was very touching and poetic.
You had the impression of being caught up
in the artist's emotional torment."
"Loving Vincent" is set to hit cinema screens
this fall.